breaking news for you this concerns the
Brazilian presidency I balsan ro who we
reported earlier this afternoon had been
tested or
was given a test for Kovac 19 let me
show you him making a statement we're
not going to listen to but let me tell
you as you look at those pictures which
I believe alive they are alive he is
testing positive for Kovac at 19 he had
been criticized by detractors who felt
he hadn't taken or treated Kovac nine
sufficiently seriously all compared to
the lockdown measures taken by other
countries and Brazil's lockdown numbers
of forgive me a coronavirus numbers were
perhaps commensurately unfeasible for
Brazil second highest global figures for
Brazil 1.6 million cases overall and
many fatalities flowing from that as a
consequence in excess of 50 facts 65,000
fatalities in Brazil so just to
underline that is coming from friends at
The Associated Press in Rio de Janeiro
they're telling us that Brazil's
president pictured there speaking live
has tested positive for Kovan 19 though
clearly still able to address the
cameras in Brazil today